[Musique]
début du printemps il ne fait pas encore
chaud chaud on est venu chercher soleil
chaleur et exotisme ici on n'est pas en
voyage on est vraiment à laval ici c'est
une serre d'à peu près 5 mai pieds
carrés au total pour le prêt de 120
arbres dans la sphère actuellement de
soin d orange dès l'hymne des citrons on
a vraiment plusieurs variétés d'agrumes
des agrumes qui pousse au québec plutôt
inusité mais aussi compliqué c'est mon
papa est parti les premiers herbe
il ya une quinzaine d'années et puis par
la suite moi j'ai repris le projet pour
en faire vraiment une entreprise un art
dé ce trompe fait à peu près la même
chose que le pommier repos me ça prend
sept ans au moins avant qu'il commence à
devenir mature et très odorant
franchement ça sent un peu le geste même
si la fleur d'agrumes la plupart des
arbres viennent du japon
yu zhu main de bouddha citron caviar
kumquat et link pire elle allait
comprendre rapidement que la production
ici est quand même très petit et limitez
donc actuellement on se limite au
restaurant au bord et aussi à certaines
petites séries microbrasserie également
c'est sûr qu'on va essayer pas d'aller
au métro où j'ai eu il y en aura pas de
chez nous parce que nous aimons
tellement des grandes quantités que je
suis pas capable par moments certains
épicerie offre aussi des grumes
évidemment ce sont des produits importés
qu'est-ce que vous cultivez à ce moment
ci de l'année
à ce moment ci de l'année on a quelques
oranges gd calamondin qui sont verts
présentement qui sont en train de
tourner au orange et j'ai des limes café
également le combat va qui sont prêts à
accueillir et ont déjà trouvé produire
des jeux trop dépendant depuis longtemps
déjà
si on à la lime café c'est un bébé plein
succès la feuille super aromatiques donc
si on veut
si on veut la sentir la feuille sens
comme la lime
donc ça c'est mathilde fait partie des
artisans qui s'inspire des agrumes de
vie qui pour créer certains de ses
chocolats jeter comme moi ou les agrumes
ici en pc c'est un produit en tout plus
divers mais locale
sous l'oeil attentif de michael et elvis
vie qui accueille une douzaine de
précieuses lim qui seront deux heures
plus tard chère mathilde de l'achat que
la tête vous venez d'avoir une livraison
spéciale
oui oui oui on adore ça ses livraisons
là en cuisine aujourd'hui c'est xavier
le frère de mathilde qui confectionnent
les yeux pour pâques à saveurs
surprenantes
on n'a vraiment pas une association
impôts sur l'idée du cari mais version
dessert c'est un oeuf au lait de coco et
enfin crème de coco au centre c'est la
lime kfir avec la coriandre un petit peu
de l'immo ci pourrait aussi un peu
l'acidité est donc dans une coque de
chocolat noir aussi un peu juteuse c'est
son geste qui servira à parfumer le
chocolat j'ai eu des gens qui ne disent
pas c'est quoi les avantages de payer du
chauffage en hiver et ses moyens
écologiques moi je continue de penser
que c'est quand même plus écologique que
les faire venir l outre mer du japon la
chine la thaïlande qui moi je sais ce
que je mets dans les armes c'est à dire
que la plupart de nos agrumes sont peu
de biologique et je met pratiquement
aucun produit
tous ces précieux fruits se congèle ce
qui permet de préserver toutes les
huiles essentielles des est pour une
utilisation ultérieure
on les congèle entière comme ça puis on
les sort on les est directement congé
youth détail à 65 à 70 dollars le kilo 1
kg contient à peu près sept à huit
yu zhu dépendamment de la grosseur et du
poids notre plus cher c'est la main de
bouddha qui est comme un agrume un peu
spéciale avec une main ça peut dérouler
entre 50 à 75 80 dollars la main donc
justement ici on a un art de bensouda
là c'est la floraison qui est en train
de se faire puis ici on voit vraiment
les bébés mâles bouddha qui est en train
de se former
chocolat et agrumes la collaboration est
récente mais le risque de se poursuivre
toute l'année par à son sort des bébés
le temps qui les gens qui grossit
d'après moi ça va être voir l'ami de
l'été environ visuellement c'est
magnifique
idéalement ce faut essayer de trouver un
petit peu de tout dans sa bouche il
c'est une bonne façon de voyager en ce
moment et découvrir des produits comme
ça c'est une grande source d'inspiration
ça paraît que ça donne d'afficher vos
résultats ce n'est pas dans notre
objectif de devenir savoura des agrumes
vraiment c'est plus on fait parce que ça
nous passionne on aime ça les agrumes
confits mon veux pas commencer à devoir
devenir une chaîne de production dix30
votre agrumes préféré ici sur lequel je
dirais que c'est le finger lime avec les
huîtres saucisses tormos puis le yu zhu
ci fait partie du top enfin on peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec mes yeux
c'est tellement un agrume différent de
tout ce qu'on connaît
[Musique]